Speaker 1: You know, we talked about
during the Trump administration,
one of the big accomplishments that took place was
Donald Trump getting a whole bunch of different
judges, confirmed three Supreme Court justices
aside, getting so many different judges confirmed
who will shape the judiciary in a right wing
direction, Trump getting ideologues and completely
unqualified people confirmed to different judge
ships. And it's important to keep track of
whether Joe Biden is able to accomplish anything
similar and to some degree, he has been now. I'm
going to give you the story first, and then I'm
going to give you the two perspectives on this
because there there are people who are saying This
is great and there are people who are saying this
is really nothing. The headline is Joe Biden
is finishing the year with the most confirmed
judicial picks dating all the way back to
Ronald Reagan, outdoing Donald Trump, certainly,
Reuters writes. President Joe Biden is wrapping
up the year with more judges confirmed to the
federal bench than any first year president since
Ronald Reagan. And experts say a growing list of
judicial vacancies could allow him to do even
better in 2022. The Senate confirmed 40 or 40,
as Joe Biden likes to say of Biden's judicial
nominees, including 11 appellate picks,
despite early concerns among progressives that he
would lack opportunities to fill seats on nation's
13 circuit courts. Biden inherited just
two appellate vacancies. Trump had 17,
and that helped Trump make a near record 234
federal court federal court appointments over four
years. We're just talking about the first year
here as Democratic appointed judges elected to go
into semi-retirement. Biden gained the opportunity
to appoint many. The White House says 78 percent
were women, 53 percent people of color. More are
expected. There's going to be votes on January 3rd
and there's going to be a whole bunch more. Biden
nominated 73 district and Circuit Court judges
overall, his 40 surpass Trump's 18 in his first
year. So there's two different interpretations
of this, and you might be thinking, how could
this be bad? OK, so on the one hand, the one
side of this that is this is bad is that this
was mostly moderates being replaced by moderates.
So the effect is that even though Joe Biden is
replacing people and getting people confirmed,
Trump was putting people in that were primarily
ideologically kooky for the right wing. So while
Joe Biden has a high number for the first year,
he's replacing moderates with moderates. These are
not ideological nut cases that in any way, they're
not ideal ideological nut nutcases on the right.
They are also not progressives who are
going to push the judiciary or pull the
judiciary back to the left in any way.
This is this is the devil's advocate.
Trump was able to actually change the judiciary
and pull it significantly to the right and where
Joe Biden is racking up confirmations. They don't
really do anything to undo that because it's
replacing moderates with moderates. OK? That's the
kind of pessimistic devil's advocate perspective.
The other interpretation would be we don't want
to go low the way they go low. We don't want
Joe Biden electing equally or nominating
and having confirmed equally incompetent
left wing ideologues. We want Joe
Biden putting in competent people
and everybody that Joe Biden has selected has
had no competency issue, whereas Donald Trump was
selecting nuts in many of these cases, completely
unqualified people. You know, both can be true is
the truth. And we've said before we. When the
system is what it is, you have to work within
the system and get what you can out of it. This is
why until we change the way redistricting is done,
for example, both Democrats and Republicans will
gerrymander to their advantage as much as they can
when, if and when given the opportunity. And we
need to change the system, OK? That's one example.
This is a different situation in my mind, and
I don't want Joe Biden selecting the equivalent
on the left of the right wing, nutty ideologues
that Donald Trump regularly selected. So I do
see this as a good thing. And the question
is going to be, can Joe Biden continue this?
Remember that Donald Trump's number was two
hundred and forty three judges in four years,
and he got three Supreme Court justices, one of
which should have been Barack Obama's selection
of Merrick Garland, which we've talked about ad
nauseum. And I'm not going to sort of refresh
for you at this point in time, but let's try to
keep it going and let's see what the tally is
in another year. But it's it is an accomplishment.
There is no question that it is an accomplishment,
and it is also true that it is mostly
the replacement of competent moderates
with other competent moderates. You tell me how
major of an accomplishment you believe it to be